o cachorro dos Estados Unidos é
porque ele obedece o dono isso é lindo
você joga o graveto cachorro corre pega
o graveto traz até você você pega fala
thanks Miles yeah sai assim
ó nosso cachorro faz isso não a gente
joga o pau cachorro fala vou buscar essa
merda esse pau velho não para buscar
você você que jogou não foi
eu tem um cachorro que é duas vezes mais
doido você joga o pau ele corre pega o
pau e vai embora para lá
ele planeja a vida dele ele e o pau só
você não tá
incluído tem um cachorro que é três
vezes mais doido que é o nosso te joga o
pau ele corre pega o pau traz até
perto você fala assim meu cachorro é
diferente quando ele chega perto fala me
dá o pau
ele ele te faz de idiota né